the global economic meltdown is the most
serious threat to American national
security and to our democracy so this
has got to be our first priority to
restore our economy and the global
economy and that's a strategic decision
I don't believe President Obama fully
grasps he says economics is the most
important thing but to exercise real
leadership real strategic leadership to
understand power you have to make
choices and set priorities you can't do
everything I know it's fashionable on
the White House to say oh you only have
a hundred or two hundred days and you've
got to get everything in before the tide
turns against you that's not right what
you've got to do is succeed and the way
to succeed is to focus not exclusively
but to focus on the main things and they
really put your muscle behind those
things by far the most important
security threat is the economic meltdown
because as I said we need that economy
to keep our democracy afloat it's the
basis of providing money to fix up
public education essential to our
democracy you can't have a democracy if
public education continues to fall apart
like like it has and it is the way we
can afford a military capability that
outstrips all the rest of the world put
together we spend as much on defense by
the book by the way as the next 25
largest spenders on the military put
together we do that because of the
strength of our economy so that's the
biggest issue for us and foreign
national security our fate is not going
to be determined in the mountains of
Afghanistan